Think for a minute about your first day. Not your first day on the job, or the first day with your spouse, or the first day in the neighborhood. I'm talking about your first first day. The first time you ever had a first day.
花一分钟想想你的第一天。不是你上班的第一天，不是你和配偶在一起的第一天，也不是搬到新社区的第一天。我说的是你真正的“第一天”。你人生中经历的第一个第一天。
Up until the time that Tarpeley was three and a half, everything was always the same. She had been in the same day care since she was six months old. Her parents were still together. They lived in the same place.
在塔普莉（Tarpeley）三岁半之前，一切都一成不变。她从六个月大开始就一直在同一家托儿所。她的父母依然在一起。他们住在同一个地方。
Her house has these rooms in it. And her backyard is this way. And her teachers are the same teachers. Her friends have been the same friends for three and a half years, which in her time frame, is all of eternity. There are no other friends. There are no other people.
她的房子里有这些房间，后院也是那个样子。她的老师还是那些老师。三岁半以来，她的朋友还是那些朋友，而在她的时间观念里，这简直就是永恒。没有其他朋友，也没有其他人。
That's her dad, our contributing editor Jack Hitt. He says that all of this changed the day that he discovered that he could switch Tarpeley to a different school, a preschool that was a lot closer to their house. As he told Tarpeley, it was a school where the big kids go. There was suddenly an opening.
那是她的父亲，我们的特约编辑杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）。他说，这一切在他发现可以给塔普莉换所学校的那天改变了，那是一所离他们家近得多的幼儿园。正如他告诉塔普莉的，那是一所大孩子去的学校。那里正好有一个名额。
So I told her about this, and she-- the idea of moving on to the next stage in her life, the first time she had ever had that option, was so exciting. She literally jumped out of her chair and ran circles around this cafeteria. Screaming, dancing, just sending up hosannas of glee.
我告诉了她这件事，她——想到要进入人生的下一个阶段，这是她第一次有这样的选择，她感到非常兴奋。她简直是从椅子上一跃而起，绕着食堂转圈。尖叫着，跳舞，发出阵阵欢快的欢呼声。
And we talked about it all weekend long. All the books tell you to do this. And it makes sense.
我们整个周末都在谈论这件事。所有的书都建议你这样做，而且这很有道理。
You talked about it all weekend long? What was there to talk about?
你们整个周末都在谈论这件事？有什么好谈的呢？
Well, just, you know, that there would be new people, and new teachers, and new everything. And that would require some getting used to. You say that to a three year old, and you think they understand what you're saying, but of course they don't. Because they don't have any experience at encountering anything new.
嗯，就是，你知道，会有新的人，新的老师，新的一切。这需要一些适应。你对一个三岁的孩子说这些，你以为他们听得懂，但他们当然不懂。因为他们没有任何面对新鲜事物的经验。
She had never had a first day before this. And comes the big day. They set out for school.
在这之前，她从没经历过第一天。大日子终于来了。他们出发去学校。
On the morning of her first day, this was Columbus setting off into the Atlantic, right? We walked up the block, and hung a right, and started down to this place that she had never seen before.
在她第一天的早晨，这就像哥伦布启航前往大西洋，对吧？我们沿着街区走，右转，开始朝那个她从未见过的地方走去。
On the first day-- any first day-- we're expected to live by the rules and customs of the culture that we're entering. But we don't know those rules and customs just yet. It is a very particular time. And all the kids at the school that Tarpeley was entering, they already knew each other from the year before. She was the newcomer.
在第一天——任何第一天——我们都被要求遵守我们所进入文化的规则和习俗。但我们对这些规则和习俗还一无所知。这是一个非常特殊的时期。而塔普莉进入的那所学校里的所有孩子，他们从前一年开始就已经互相认识了。她是那个新人。
I can't remember if it was the first day or the second day. But I remember the gut-wrenching moment was when I came to pick her up one day and we were walking home. And she started to cry, and said that she wanted to go back to her other school. And the reason was that one of the little children there had told her that she couldn't play with them. That there was this little group, and my daughter wasn't invited to play with them, because they didn't know her, and that she should stay away from them. She had never heard that expression or that idea in her life.
我不记得是第一天还是第二天了。但我记得那个令人揪心的时刻，有一天我去接她，我们正往家走。她开始哭，说她想回到原来的学校。原因是那里的一个小孩告诉她，不许她和他们一起玩。有一个小团体，我的女儿没有被邀请加入，因为他们不认识她，还说她应该离他们远点。她这辈子从来没听过那种说法，也没见过那种主意。
And of course what's interesting is that the person who made that remark to her is now one of her best friends.
当然，有趣的是，那个对她说这话的人现在成了她最好的朋友之一。
What do you make of that?
你对此怎么看？
Well, I think that hazing is a natural part of defining any group. And I don't know why. But there's not a profession or a career or a group out there that, on some level, doesn't have some ritual in which the new member is either tormented, or tortured, or beaten, or humiliated.
嗯，我认为欺凌是定义任何群体的自然组成部分。我不知道为什么。但外面没有任何职业、事业或群体，在某种程度上，不包含某种让新成员受到折磨、虐待、殴打或羞辱的仪式。
Jack is kind of collecting examples. When he was a freshman at a military boarding school when he was a kid, the freshmen were called "rats." This is common. Upperclassmen would wake them up in the middle of the night, tell them to go warm the toilet seats for them. Jack's wife is a medical student. And you know residents, they work 40 hours without a break, taking the worst cases, doing the worst work, delirious from sleep deprivation. you have to do all that before the older doctors welcome you into the club, give you the keys to their Mercedes.
杰克正在收集这方面的例子。他小时候在一所军事寄宿学校读一年级时，新生被称为“老鼠”。这很常见。高年级学生会在半夜叫醒他们，让他们去给他们温热马桶座圈。杰克的妻子是一名医科学生。你知道实习医生，他们连续工作40个小时不休息，处理最严重的病例，做最累的工作，因为缺乏睡眠而产生幻觉。在老医生欢迎你加入俱乐部、把奔驰车的钥匙交给你之前，你必须经历这一切。
The whole thing reminds me of the way gangs work here in Chicago. Joining a gang here in Chicago, or really a lot of places around the country, means that you get jumped in. Your future gang brothers or sisters take you into an alley and beat the hell out of you.
这一切让我想起了芝加哥帮派的运作方式。在芝加哥，或者实际上全国许多地方，加入帮派意味着你得经受“入伙礼”。你未来的帮派兄弟姐妹会把你拉进小巷里，把你打个半死。
There is just something primal and intimate about the entire thing, as if the existence of the first day, the simple presence of an outsider who wants to be an insider, is so profound, so disturbing to any group, that they have to crush you, prove you harmless, before they welcome you into the family. This is the disturbing aura that surrounds the first day.
这一切确实有一种原始而亲密的意味，仿佛第一天的存在，一个想要成为内部人的局外人的简单出现，是如此深刻，如此令任何群体感到不安，以至于他们必须先摧毁你，证明你无害，然后才欢迎你进入家庭。这就是笼罩在第一天周围那令人不安的光环。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, First Day, the story of outsiders who show up wanting to be insiders, and what it takes to make the jump.
好了，这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天我们的节目主题是“第一天”，讲述的是那些想要成为内部人的局外人，以及为了实现这一跨越所需要付出的代价。
Act One, Lost at Sea. How cussing can get you through moments when reason fails. The story of a lowly dishwasher who gets a job on an oil rig off the Louisiana coast. Act Two, Squirrel Cop. The story of a rookie cop that is so, so pleasurable that all week around the office, here at the radio station, we have been cracking each other up simply by walking up to each other and saying the words, "Squirrel cop." Act Three, Bad Sex with Bud Kemp. Sandra Tsing Loh with a story about the first day of new love. Well, an attempt at new love. Act Four, When Businesses Act Like Humans. The story of an entire corporation having its first day, and how it makes all the mistakes that any of us would make on our first day on the job. Stay with us. You will not be disappointed.
第一幕，迷失海上。咒骂如何能助你度过理智失效的时刻。一个卑微的洗碗工在路易斯安那州海岸外的一个石油钻井平台上找到了一份工作。第二幕，松鼠警官。这个菜鸟警察的故事是如此、如此有趣，以至于整个星期在广播电台办公室里，我们只需走到对方身边说出“松鼠警官”这几个字，就能让对方笑得前仰后合。第三幕，与巴德·肯普（Bud Kemp）的糟糕性爱。桑德拉·清·罗（Sandra Tsing Loh）带来的关于新恋情第一天的故事。嗯，一次尝试性的新恋情。第四幕，当企业像人类一样行事。一个大公司经历它的第一天，以及它如何犯下我们任何人在工作第一天都会犯的所有错误。请留在我们身边。你不会失望的。
Act One, Lost at Sea. Well, regular listeners to our show may remember Dishwasher Pete. He is an actual dishwasher who, for over eight years, has been pursuing his quest to wash dishes in every state of the union. He is up to 33 states. To score at Louisiana, he thought that he would try to get a job on an oil rig out in the Gulf of Mexico, but there was one problem. It would mean breaking what Pete calls the fundamental rule.
第一幕，迷失海上。嗯，我们节目的常客可能还记得“洗碗工皮特”（Dishwasher Pete）。他是一位真正的洗碗工，八年多来，他一直在追求在全美每个州洗盘子的目标。他已经完成了33个州。为了拿下路易斯安那州，他想尝试在墨西哥湾的一个石油钻井平台上找份工作，但有一个问题。这意味着要打破皮特所谓的“基本准则”。
Basically, the rule is this. Never work at a job where I can't quit and leave the moment the notion struck me. For 10 years, ever since I had established the fundamental rule, I had never broken it.
基本来说，这个准则就是：永远不要从事那种一旦产生念头就无法立即辞职离开的工作。十年来，自从我定下这个基本准则后，我从未打破过它。
He wanted to try, though. If you could handle two weeks on an oil rig, maybe-- just maybe-- he could dare to head off to a bigger dream of his, to wash dishes on a fishing boat for months off the coast of Alaska. With that in mind, he set off to test the fundamental rule.
但他想试一试。如果你能在石油钻井平台上坚持两周，也许——只是也许——他可以敢于去追求他更大的梦想，在阿拉斯加海岸外的渔船上洗几个月的盘子。怀着这样的想法，他出发去测试那个基本准则。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] the company that supplied galley hands for oil rigs in a small town outside New Orleans. I filled out a bunch of paperwork and sat around with a half dozen other applicants. When my name was finally called, I walked down a hall to where a guy greeted me.
……那家为新奥尔良郊外一个小镇的石油钻井平台提供厨房工人的公司。我填了一堆表格，和其他半打申请者坐在一起。当我的名字最终被叫到时，我沿着走廊走进一个男人招呼我的地方。
Too stunned to catch his name, I could only stare at him and think, "My god, it's Bill Clinton." He was an absolute dead ringer for Bill Clinton. I couldn't take my eyes off him as he led me into his office. The resemblance was remarkable. He had the same puffy cheeks, the same dimpled chin, and the same salt and pepper hair and haircut. He even had that familiar Clinton smirk, only this guy's smirk seemed to say, I know you think I look like Clinton, and you're dying to ask me about it.
我被惊呆了，甚至没听清他的名字，只能盯着他想：“天哪，是比尔·克林顿。”他简直和比尔·克林顿长得一模一样。当他带我进办公室时，我的目光无法从他身上移开。这种相似性太惊人了。他有着同样的浮肿脸颊、同样的酒窝下巴、同样的椒盐色头发和发型。他甚至有那种熟悉的克林顿式假笑，只是这个人的假笑似乎在说：我知道你觉得我像克林顿，你正渴望问我这件事。
The Clinton clone said, I had left a couple things blank on my application, such as the make and license plate number of my car. "I don't have a car," I said.
克林顿的“克隆人”说，我在申请表上留空了几处，比如车的品牌和车牌号。“我没有车，”我说。
"You don't? Why not?"
“没有？为什么？”
"Um, I guess I just don't need one."
“嗯，我想我就是不需要。”
"Well, you need one for this job. In fact, owning a car is the most important qualification for being a galley hand."
“嗯，这份工作你需要。事实上，拥有一辆车是成为厨房工人最重要的资质。”
"I have to own a car to wash dishes on an oil rig?"
“我必须有车才能在石油钻井平台上洗碗？”
"That's right. When you're on call, and the dispatcher calls and tells you to be down at the coast in three hours, you have to be there. We can't wait for you to find a car to borrow or to find someone to drive you."
“没错。当你待命时，调度员打电话让你三小时内赶到海岸，你必须在那里。我们不能等你去找车借，或者找人送你。”
"Oh, well, in that case, I do own a car."
“噢，好吧，如果是那样的话，我确实有一辆车。”
"Great. What kind?"
“太好了。什么车？”
"It's a station wagon."
“是一辆旅行车。”
"And what's the license plate number?"
“车牌号是多少？”
"I'm not sure."
“我不确定。”
"You don't know your own license plate number?"
“你不知道你自己的车牌号？”
"Well, I'd have to go outside and check on it."
“嗯，我得出去看看。”
"You go do that, then."
“那你去吧。”
I stepped outside and wrote down the license plate number of a car that I hoped wasn't his, and then went back in and gave it to him. Minutes later, I was issued a hard hat, safety glasses, and two work shirts. I was now officially on call.
我走到外面，记下了一辆车的车牌号，希望那车不是他的，然后回去交给了他。几分钟后，我领到了一顶安全帽、护目镜和两件工作服。我现在正式处于待命状态了。
I spent the rest of the afternoon walking back to the city, grasping at my last fleeting moments of freedom. I was on the verge of breaking the fundamental rule, and could foresee only disaster. To make my fretting worse, the next day a friend of a friend, who claimed to be familiar with life on the oil rigs, told me I could expect to be hazed. As if overcoming my occupational claustrophobia wasn't enough, I was going to have to put up with idiots hazing me, as well.
那天剩下的时间我都在走回城市的路上，抓住我最后一点转瞬即逝的自由。我正处于打破基本准则的边缘，只能预见到灾难。更让我烦心的是，第二天一个朋友的朋友，据称很了解石油钻井平台生活，告诉我我可能会被欺凌。好像克服我的职业幽闭恐惧症还不够，我还得忍受那些白痴对我的欺凌。
Two days later, I was flown to an oil rig in the Gulf of Mexico. The helicopter approached the center of three connected platforms and landed on the roof of its uppermost structure. I asked the pilot, "Where would I find the galley?" "Go down those stairs, and someone will show you," he said. I took off my headset, put on my hardhat and safety glasses, grabbed my bag, and hopped out. I held the door open, reluctant to break my link to the outside world. "So where did you say the galley was?" I shouted over the roar of the whirling blades. "Just go down those stairs," the pilot shouted back. "Shut the door."
两天后，我被送往墨西哥湾的一个石油钻井平台。直升机靠近三个相连平台中心，降落在最高建筑的屋顶上。我问飞行员：“我在哪能找到厨房？”“顺着那些楼梯下去，会有人带你的，”他说。我摘下耳机，戴上安全帽和护目镜，抓起包，跳了下去。我扶着门，不愿切断与外面世界的联系。“所以你说厨房在哪？”我在旋转叶片的轰鸣声中大喊。“顺着楼梯下去就行，”飞行员大喊回道。“关上门。”
I shut the door and ran across the roof. As I dashed down the stairs, the helicopter revved up. I paused momentarily, but resisted the temptation to run back up to the roof. The fundamental rule had been broken. There was nothing left to do but face the consequences.
我关上门，跑过屋顶。当我冲下楼梯时，直升机轰鸣着启动了。我短暂地停顿了一下，但克制住了跑回屋顶的冲动。基本准则已经被打破了。除了面对后果，别无他法。
Down the stairs, I popped my head through an open door and asked a guy which way to the galley. "Go this way and that," he said. "Down these stairs and those. Can't miss it." I followed his directions and found myself out in the middle of the platform, surrounded by cargo containers and pipes and assorted industrial junk.
顺着楼梯，我把头探进一扇开着的门，问一个人厨房怎么走。“往那边走再往那边，”他说。“顺着这些楼梯下去，再走那些。错不了的。”我照着他的指示，发现自己站在平台的中央，周围堆满了集装箱、管道和各种工业废料。
"You passed it. The door is back that way." A guy in a tiny window of one of the cargo containers pointed back the way I came. I looked, but didn't find any doors. Apparently, a little fun was already being had at the new guy's expense. Were they going to lead me all over the damn rig searching for the galley? I cursed myself for letting the helicopter leave without me.
“你走过了。门在往回走那边。”一个集装箱小窗户里的家伙指着我刚才走回来的方向。我看了看，没发现任何门。显然，别人已经拿这个新人开涮了。他们打算带我绕着该死的钻井平台转一圈找厨房吗？我诅咒自己让直升机在我没上去的情况下飞走了。
Then I noticed a piece of cardboard that had scrawled handwriting written on it. It read, "Keep out. This means you. Wet floor. Signed, Redneck." The sign hung from what I realized was a door handle. I tugged and pulled and turned the handle every which way, but couldn't get the damn door to budge. I was so green, I couldn't even unlock a simple latch.
然后我注意到一块写着乱涂乱画手迹的纸板。上面写着：“禁止进入。说的是你。地面潮湿。签名，乡巴佬。”牌子挂在我意识到是一个门把手的东西上。我拉、扯、转动把手，试遍了所有方法，但这该死的门就是纹丝不动。我真是太菜了，连个简单的插销都打不开。
I was helpless until, almost magically, the door opened from the inside. In front of me stood the guy I had seen through the window. "[BLEEP], son," he said. "Don't just stand there playing with yourself. Come on in." He introduced himself as Redneck, the galley steward. My boss.
我束手无策，直到门几乎像变魔术一样从里面打开了。站在我面前的是我刚才从窗户里看到的那个家伙。“[哔——]，伙计，”他说。“别站在那玩弄你自己了。进来吧。”他自我介绍说是“乡巴佬”（Redneck），厨房领班。我的老板。
I stepped inside and asked him where the galley was. "Man, you're in the mother[BLEEP] galley," he scoffed. Looking around, I was pretty sure he had to be putting me on. Even though I could see a small kitchen, the whole space was barely bigger than the kitchen and dining room of a house.
我走进去，问他厨房在哪里。“伙计，你就在这该死的厨房里，”他嘲笑道。环顾四周，我敢肯定他一定是在耍我。虽然我能看到一个小厨房，但整个空间几乎比不上家里厨房和餐厅的大小。
"Where does everybody eat, then?" I asked.
“那大家都在哪吃饭？”我问。
"Right [BLEEP] there," Redneck said, kicking one of the two benches that faced the counter along one wall. Obviously, 100 employees couldn't fit on those two benches, but since he seemed to think I was gullible, I played along. "Yeah, OK," I said.
“就在[哔——]那儿，”乡巴佬说着，踢了踢靠墙的一排柜台前的两条长凳之一。显然，100名员工是不可能坐得下那两条长凳的，但既然他觉得我很好骗，我就顺着他说。“是的，好吧，”我说。
The rig clerk, acting as the official welcoming committee, arrived right behind me. He instructed me what to do in case of an emergency. "If there's an explosion," he said, "run to whatever platform isn't burning."
钻井平台职员作为官方欢迎委员会，紧跟在我后面到达了。他告诉我紧急情况下该怎么做。“如果发生爆炸，”他说，“跑到任何一个没有着火的平台上。”
Redneck, as I would later learn he insisted on being called, introduced me to Cuz, the other galley hand, who was mopping the kitchen. My job instructions from Redneck were simple. "As long as you keep them [BLEEP] dishes clean, there ain't a mother[BLEEP] on this rig who'd give you [BLEEP]."
乡巴佬（我后来才知道他坚持让人这么称呼他）把我介绍给了厨房的另一位工人“库兹”（Cuz），他正在拖地。乡巴佬给我的工作指示很简单：“只要你把那些[哔——]盘子洗干净，这平台上就没有哪个[哔——]会找你[哔——]麻烦。”
After a brief tour of the small kitchen, Redneck showed me to my station. I stepped up to the sinks and assumed by preferred dishwashing stance. Looking straight ahead, I saw heaven. Right there above the sinks, perfectly at eye level, was a porthole. I immediately knew that this little window to the world would play a huge role in helping me survive for two weeks without quitting. I looked out at the endless expanse of the Gulf of Mexico. There wasn't much to look at-- a whole lot of sea, a whole lot of sky, and dozens of rigs off in the distance-- but already, I felt at ease.
简单参观了小厨房后，乡巴佬带我去了我的岗位。我走到水槽前，摆出了我惯用的洗碗姿势。抬头平视，我看见了天堂。就在水槽上方，恰好视线水平的位置，是一个舷窗。我立刻意识到，这扇小小的世界之窗将在我两周不辞职的生存中发挥巨大作用。我望向无边无际的墨西哥湾。没太多可看的——只有大海、天空，远处几十个钻井平台——但我已经感到安心了。
My gaze was broken by Redneck repeatedly saying, "Hey, pardner. Hey, pardner!" I didn't initially recognize my new nickname. "Hey, pardner," he said. "You don't [BLEEP] cuss much, do you?" "No," I answered. "Not really." "Well [BLEEP]," he said. "I'll have to mother[BLEEP] cuss for the both of us, then." And he did. Then it was time for lunch.
我的凝视被乡巴佬反复说的“嘿，伙计。嘿，伙计！”所打破。起初我没认出我的新绰号。“嘿，伙计，”他说，“你不怎么[哔——]骂人，是吧？”“不，”我回答。“真的不。”“那[哔——]，”他说，“那我得替我们俩[哔——]骂了。”他确实这么做了。然后到了吃午饭的时间。
Redneck explained that, despite the fact that the rig was comprised of three connected platforms, the crew was actually pretty small. Altogether, there were about 30 people to be fed. Their mealtimes were staggered. So there were never more than five or six guys in the galley at any given time. This slow but steady pace applied to the dishes as well. There were always dishes for me to wash, but never any rush to get them done.
乡巴佬解释说，尽管钻井平台由三个相连的平台组成，但船员其实很少。总共只有大约30人需要喂饱。他们的用餐时间是错开的。所以任何时候厨房里都不会超过五六个人。这种缓慢但稳定的节奏也适用于洗碗工作。总有盘子要洗，但从来不需要赶进度。
Several times during lunch, crew hands walked up to me in the kitchen with big grins on their faces and asked, "How's it going, bro?" "OK," I'd shrug. They waited. For what, I had no idea. They waited, and then they grew irritated with me and stomped out of the kitchen. One guy said, "What's this quiet-ass mother[BLEEP]'s problem, Redneck?" "He likes looking out that [BLEEP] window. What can I say?" I didn't understand. I washed the dishes, I looked out the window, I minded my own business, just as Redneck had instructed. Why would anyone have a problem with that?
午餐时，好几次工人们满脸笑容地走到厨房，问我：“怎么样，兄弟？”“挺好，”我耸耸肩。他们等着。等着什么，我完全没头绪。他们等着，然后对我感到恼火，气冲冲地离开了厨房。一个人说：“这个安静得要命的[哔——]有什么毛病，乡巴佬？”“他喜欢盯着那个[哔——]窗户看。我能说什么？”我不明白。我洗盘子，我看着窗外，我做好我自己的事，正如乡巴佬指示的那样。为什么会有人对此有意见？
After a few more of these encounters over the next couple of days, I finally realized what was going on. The rig hands, after working a gritty shift of roustabouting and roughnecking, expected to be greeted in the galley with some witty remark or joke, maybe even a song or dance. They expected the galley hand to provide some comic relief, like a court jester. What they got instead was me washing dishes and staring out at the sea.
在接下来的几天里又发生几次这样的接触后，我终于意识到是怎么回事了。钻井工人在经历了粗活累活的脏班次后，期望在厨房里得到一些机智的调侃或笑话，甚至是一首歌或一段舞蹈。他们期望厨房工能像小丑一样提供一些喜剧调剂。而他们得到的却是我洗着盘子盯着大海看。
Well, too bad. I wasn't there to entertain anyone. If I wanted a job shucking and jiving for diners, I would have become a waiter.
嗯，真遗憾。我不是为了取悦任何人而来的。如果我想找一份为食客跳舞卖艺的工作，我就去当服务员了。
Redneck was never at ease. He raced back and forth across the tiny kitchen when he cooked, a constant stream of chatter flowing from his lips. He was a fun and funny guy, but he had a nervous edge that was attributed by all, including himself, to the seven years he spent as a CIA mercenary in southeast Asia during the Vietnam War. I never saw Redneck sit down for more than 30 seconds before he jumped up again and resumed his frantic pacing.
乡巴佬从没闲着。他做饭时在狭小的厨房里来回奔跑，嘴里喋喋不休。他是一个有趣的人，但他有一种紧张的神经，包括他自己在内，大家都把这归因于他在越南战争期间作为中央情报局雇佣兵在东南亚度过的七年。我从未见过乡巴佬坐下超过30秒，然后他又跳起来恢复那种疯狂的踱步。
He grew especially nervous when he and I were alone in the galley, and I stood staring out my porthole. "Goddamn, pardner! Say [BLEEP] something!" If I had nothing to say, usually I just cursed, since he got a kick out of that. "[BLEEP] it," I'd say. "You got that right, pardner," he'd laugh. "[BLEEP] it." Then, after further contemplation, he'd add, "Mother[BLEEP] it."
当我和他单独在厨房里，我站在那盯着舷窗时，他变得格外紧张。“该死的，伙计！说点[哔——]话吧！”如果我没话可说，通常我就骂几句，因为他很喜欢这个。“[哔——]的，”我会说。“你说对了，伙计，”他会大笑。“[哔——]的。”然后，进一步深思后，他会补充说：“[哔——]它。”
Not an hour passed without Redneck raising one of his favorite topics for discussion, sex with farm animals. Redneck was raised on a farm in Arkansas, and was quite knowledgeable about having sex with farm animals, and wasn't stingy with this information. He was also always prepared to discuss his other favorite topic whenever Cuz was around, the various ways to kill a man. Between Redneck's experiences in southeast Asia and Cuz's experiences in street gangs and prison, they had plenty of stories to share and information to exchange. Sometimes when I broke from my daydreaming at the window, I found it difficult to decipher exactly which topic Redneck was presently discussing. "You just sneak up behind them and get your arms around his [BLEEP] neck like that, and that [BLEEP] is all yours."
没有一个小时是不提到他最喜欢讨论的话题之一的：与农场动物发生性关系。乡巴佬在阿肯色州的一个农场长大，对与农场动物发生性行为非常了解，而且对这些信息并不吝啬。只要库兹在场，他也随时准备讨论他另一个最喜欢的话题：各种杀人的方法。介于乡巴佬在东南亚的经历和库兹在街头帮派和监狱里的经历，他们有讲不完的故事和交换的信息。有时，当我在窗边走神被打断时，我发现很难分辨乡巴佬到底在讨论哪个话题。“你只要悄悄走到他们后面，把你的手臂像这样围住他的[哔——]脖子，那[哔——]就全是你的了。”
Every day, the Gulf went through a metamorphosis. For hours on end, I watched the endless expanse of water slosh up and down, back and forth, as the parade of fish, porpoises, seaweed, stingrays, driftwood, and jellyfish swam and floated past. Seabirds soared by on a fixed course to some unseen destination beyond the horizon.
每一天，海湾都在经历蜕变。几个小时的时间里，我看着无尽的广阔水域上下起伏，来回摆动，看着鱼群、海豚、海草、黄貂鱼、浮木和水母从身边游过或漂过。海鸟沿着固定的航线飞向地平线外某个看不见的目的地。
I eyed the dozens of other oil rigs that stood 5, 10, 20 miles across the watery plain. Some appeared no bigger than a blip on the horizon. I wondered a lot about the galley hands on those rigs who were staring back at the blip that was our rig.
我注视着水面上5英里、10英里、20英里外矗立的几十个石油钻井平台。有些看起来在地平线上不过是个小点。我常常好奇那些钻井平台上的厨房工人是不是也在盯着我们这个钻井平台的小点。
The more I stared out at the Gulf, the more transfixed I became by the water. There was water as far as I could see, in all directions. I was surrounded by it. I was trapped by it. My hands soaked in it. I drank it constantly. The more I stared at the water, the less I understood it.
我越盯着墨西哥湾，就越被水所吸引。所见之处，四面八方都是水。我被它包围了。我被它困住了。我的手浸在水里。我一直在喝它。我越盯着水看，就越不理解它。
The hazing I had feared as a greenhorn never materialized. As each day passed, I felt more confident I could last the full two weeks without quitting. The countdown to departure ticked away rapidly. Three days and a wakeup, two days and a wakeup, one day and a wakeup. Finally there was nothing left but a wakeup. No more shifts to work, no more dishes to wash. Just had to wake up and jump on the helicopter.
我担心的那种菜鸟欺凌从未发生。随着每一天过去，我觉得自己能坚持两周不辞职的信心更强了。离别的倒计时迅速流逝。三天加一个起床号，两天加一个起床号，一天加一个起床号。最终只剩下一个起床号了。没有更多的轮班要上，没有更多的盘子要洗。只要醒来跳上直升机就行。
I thought back to the day I landed on the rig. At the end of my first shift, Cookie, the night cook, had asked me, "This your first day on a rig?" "Yeah," I said. "Well, the first day is the worst, and all the rest are just the same."
我回想起我登上钻井平台的那天。第一班结束时，夜班厨师“曲奇”（Cookie）问我：“这是你在钻井平台的第一天？”“是啊，”我说。“嗯，第一天是最糟糕的，剩下所有的日子都一样。”
Dishwasher Pete's story was first published in the zine he writes and publishes, Dishwasher.
洗碗工皮特的文章最初发表在他自己撰写和发行的杂志《洗碗工》上。
[MUSIC - "WORKING FOR THE MAN" BY RAY ORBISON]
[音乐 - 雷·奥比森 (Roy Orbison) 的《为老板工作》]
Act Two, Squirrel Cop.
第二幕，松鼠警官。
The first day, among other things, means human error. It means mistakes. It means mishap.  It means fiasco. That is true on a job or anywhere else that the first day occurs. You don't know the ropes. What else could happen? We have this story from a police officer, now a veteran of the force, in a suburban community on the East Coast.
第一天，除了其他含义外，意味着人为失误。意味着错误。意味着事故。意味着惨败。无论是在工作还是在任何其他发生第一天的场合都是如此。你还没摸清门道。还会发生什么呢？我们有这样一个来自东海岸郊区社区的一位警察，如今已是警界老兵的故事。
There was nothing, nothing going on. Saturday night in this village. Really quiet. Super cold. And this call came over for unknown animal in a house. And it was on my post. It was about five minutes away.
那是这个村庄一个周六的晚上，什么事都没有，非常安静，超级冷。这时收到一个关于屋内出现不明动物的报警。那是我的辖区，距离大约五分钟路程。
So myself and another car were assigned the call. And we show up there. And luckily for me, it was another guy who was pretty new. So we walk up to the door with all our stuff on. The nylon coat, the vest, the belt, the whole nine yards.
我和另一辆巡逻车被指派去处理这个报警。我们到了那儿。幸运的是，对方也是个相当新的警察。所以我们穿戴着所有装备走上门去：尼龙外套、背心、腰带，整套行头。
And the door opens, and the guy who is behind the door, he's about 30. I was 23 at the time. He's about 30. He looks like a broker, a lawyer.  Just really well put together. A nice guy wearing glasses. He's wearing these silk pajamas with a monogram. Got my attention. And he's going, listen, I'm really sorry to bother you. Normally I'd handle this sort of stuff on my own. But my wife really insisted I call.
门开了，站在门后的男人大约30岁。我当时23岁。他看起来像个经纪人或律师，整理得非常利落，是个戴着眼镜的好人。他穿着绣有姓名缩写的丝绸睡衣，吸引了我的注意力。他在说：“听着，真的很抱歉打扰你们。通常我能自己处理这类事情。但我妻子一定要我打电话。”
And so we ask him what the problem is. He says, well, we were having kind of a romantic evening down in the living room, and we heard this scratching upstairs. So I ran upstairs to see what it was. And it turns out it's coming from the attic. There's something up there, and it's just running around, knocking a few small things over. I can't tell what it is. It could be a squirrel or raccoon. I really don't know.
我们问他问题是什么。他说：“嗯，我们刚才在客厅度过了一个浪漫的夜晚，然后我们听到了楼上有抓挠声。所以我跑上楼看是什么。结果发现是从阁楼传出来的。那里有些东西，正在到处跑，撞倒了一些小东西。我看不出是什么。可能是松鼠或浣熊。我真的不知道。”
So the other cop that I was with said, well, you know, we really don't handle that. It's not so much a police function. But we do have numbers of these private contractors who will come in and they'll put a humane trap down, and they'll remove the animal for you. It's really not such a big deal. But it's really not our thing.
所以我身边的另一位警察说：“嗯，你知道，我们真的不处理那种事。那不太属于警察职责范围。但我们有这些私营承包商的电话，他们会过来放一个人道陷阱，把动物清理走。那其实没多大不了的。但真的不是我们的工作。”
So right as he was in the middle of saying that and getting us off the hook, the guy swings the door back, and there is his wife, who was just beautiful. She was beautiful. She was probably about 26 or 27, but just really beautiful. Perfect skin, long blond hair, great teeth, brilliant blue eyes, a really nice smile. Just, like, beautiful and friendly. You know? If she had said, eat this broken glass, I just would have said, OK, broken glass it is. It's fine.
正当他说话说到一半想打发掉我们时，男人把门打开，他的妻子出现在那里，她真是太漂亮了。她非常漂亮。大概26或27岁，真的非常美。完美的皮肤，长长的金发，漂亮的牙齿，灿烂的蓝眼睛，非常甜美的微笑。就是那种，又漂亮又友好。你知道吗？如果她当时说，“把这块碎玻璃吃掉”，我肯定会说：“好的，吃碎玻璃。”没问题。
But she seemed really nice. So I was going to be, like, Galahad. So I just threw my arm back into this guy's chest, into my partner's chest. And I said, Mark, we can handle this. It'll be OK.
但她看起来真的很不错。所以我打算当个“加拉哈德”（Galahad，骑士精神的象征）。于是我猛地把胳膊向后一挥，顶在那个男人、顶在我搭档的胸口上。我说：“马克，我们能处理，没问题的。”
And she was just, oh, thank you so much. And she was really sweet. And I was, like, struck dead. So we walk inside. And she goes, I'm going to throw a pot of coffee on. And we go upstairs. We follow the man of the house upstairs. And we're underneath one of those trapdoors that goes into the attic with the staircase that folds out.
她不停地说：“噢，太谢谢你们了。”她真的很甜。我被迷得神魂颠倒。我们走进屋内。她说：“我去煮壶咖啡。”我们上楼。我们跟着这家的男主人上了楼。我们在那块通往阁楼的活板门下面，那上面有折叠下来的楼梯。
And we do hear an animal upstairs scratching away, just kind of scuttling around the floor. And there's definitely something up there. And it's making pretty good speed going from one end of the roof to the other. So I reached up, and I took the trapdoor down. We unfolded the ladder.
我们确实听见楼上有动物在抓挠，就在地板上跑来跑去。那上面肯定有东西。它正以相当快的速度从屋顶的一端跑到另一端。所以我伸出手，把活板门拉了下来。我们展开梯子。
Now I have this big, heavy flashlight, your cop flashlight. The 4 D-cells, the metal case, the whole thing. I shine it up through the hole in there. And it's pretty black. I can see the rafters, but really nothing else around there. And I start up the latter. Now, the guy who owned the house is standing almost directly underneath me, just to the side of the latter, looking straight up at me. And my partner's at the base of the latter, right behind me.
现在我拿着这支大而沉的手电筒，就是那种警察专用的，用4节D型电池的金属外壳的那种。我顺着洞往上照。里面非常黑。我能看到椽子，但周围什么也看不见。我开始上梯子。这时，屋主站在我正下方，就在梯子边上，抬头盯着我看。我的搭档就在梯子底部，就在我后面。
So just before I stuck my head through this black hole, I just kind of pause. I crunch my body up underneath, because I'm realizing, gee, I don't know where this thing is. The second we pulled down the trap door, all noise upstairs just ceased. So I was kind of nervous. And I was like, well, you know, I look like an idiot, just crouched up here on the top of the ladder. So I took the flashlight, and I just popped my head up, turned the light on again.
就在我把头伸进那个黑洞之前，我停顿了一下。我把身体蜷缩在下方，因为我意识到，天哪，我不知道那东西在哪。就在我们拉下活板门的那一刻，楼上所有的噪音都消失了。所以我有点紧张。我心想，哦，我看起来像个白痴，就这样蹲在梯子顶端。所以我拿着手电筒，把头探了进去，再次打开灯。
And about six inches from the front of my face was this squirrel, at eye level with me, kind of reared back on its legs. And I swear, from where I was standing, it looked like Godzilla. It just scared the heck out of me. I thought, it's a squirrel. It's going to be hiding somewhere. It's going to be terrified of me. It was six inches away from me. And it really startled me. So I kind of went, "ah!" And jumped back.
离我脸部前方大约六英寸处就是那只松鼠，和我视线齐平，后腿立着。我发誓，从我站的角度看，它看起来就像哥斯拉。它真的把我吓坏了。我心想：这只是只松鼠。它肯定会躲在什么地方。它肯定会怕我怕得要命。可它就离我六英寸远。它真的吓到我了。所以我喊了一声“啊！”，往后一跳。
And the flashlight slips out of my hands-- and it's heavy-- and it falls directly onto the nose of the guy who's looking straight up at me. And I don't think it broke it, but it did some damage. And his nose-- his hands up to his face, blood just started pouring out between his hands.
手电筒从我手中滑落——那是很重的——直接砸在正抬头看着我的那个男人的鼻子上。我不觉得骨折了，但造成了一些损害。他的手捂住脸，血顺着手指缝涌了出来。
This is the homeowner?
这是房主？
This is the homeowner. I lose my balance and fall backwards, directly onto my partner, and I just pancake him. We're both our backs. He's on his back. I'm on his stomach, on my back, scuttling around like a beetle, trying to get up in this really narrow hallway. It's a mess.
这是房主。我失去平衡向后倒去，直接砸在搭档身上，我把他整个压扁了。我们都背朝地。他仰面躺着。我在他肚子上仰面躺着，像只甲壳虫一样乱动，试图在这个狭窄的走廊里爬起来。简直一团糟。
The squirrel, while we're floundering around in the hallway, jumps down the stairs-- boink, boink, boink-- lands on me, and takes off down the stairs.
那只松鼠在我们走廊里挣扎时，跳下了楼梯——蹦、蹦、蹦——落在我也身上，然后顺着楼梯跑了。
How undignified.
多丢脸啊。
It was terrible. It was terrible. So we're wondering, gee, where is the squirrel? And right at that second, the woman who lived there, you hear her scream. So my partner goes, well, we found the squirrel. It's wherever she is.
太糟糕了。太糟糕了。所以我们在想，天哪，松鼠在哪？就在那一秒，住在那里的人，你听到她尖叫了。所以我搭档说：“嗯，我们找到松鼠了。它在无论她在哪的地方。”
So we go running downstairs. And the squirrel had come into the living room, where they had been having their romantic evening. They had a fire going. They had pillows arranged around one corner of the couch next to the fire, and they had champagne flutes out. Nice house. Really nice. I mean, it just smelled brand new. New carpeting, new rugs, new paint. They hadn't been there for that long.
于是我们冲下楼。那只松鼠进了客厅，也就是他们度过浪漫夜晚的地方。他们烧着火，火边沙发的一角布置着枕头，香槟杯还摆在那。漂亮的房子，真的很漂亮。我的意思是，闻起来全是新装修的味道。新地毯、新垫子、新油漆。他们搬进来没多久。
So the squirrel, when it bolted down the staircase, took off into the living room and ran underneath the couch for cover. So we run downstairs. This guy is bleeding all over the place, on his carpets. His wife looks and says, what have you done to my husband? I start going, oh, it was an accident-- and then I just stop in mid-sentence. What's the point? We've only been there about two minutes.
所以松鼠顺着楼梯冲下来时，钻到沙发底下躲起来了。我们冲下楼。这男的血流了一地，满地都是血。他妻子看着说：“你们对我丈夫做了什么？”我刚想说：“噢，是个意外——”然后我就停下了。说什么呢？我们才在那儿待了两分钟。
So the squirrel is underneath the couch. And my partner is going, let's get out of here. This is just-- it's not going well. So I am not beaten yet. I always have another idea.
所以松鼠在沙发底下。我搭档说：“我们走吧。这事——太不顺利了。”但我还没认输。我总是有点子。
So the squirrel is under this couch, which in the middle of the room. So I have this bright idea. Why don't we move the furniture away from one of the corners? And we'll put the catch in the corner. And the squirrel will probably move along with the couch, because it's the only cover available to it. And once we get into the corner, we'll only have two open sides of the couch to worry about. So we did that.
松鼠在沙发下，那沙发在房间中间。我心生一计。为什么我们不把家具从一个角落移开？我们把陷阱放进角落里。松鼠可能会随着沙发一起移出来，因为那是它唯一能躲的地方。一旦我们把它赶进角落，就只需要担心沙发剩下两个开放面了。我们就这么干了。
That is so tactical.
这战术真棒。
Yes. Yeah, I was very proud of myself at that instant. But you know.
是的，是的，那一刻我为自己感到非常骄傲。但你知道的。
I asked her for a box. And she says, sure, we've got boxes. We just moved in. We have nothing but boxes. She runs out to the garage. And she comes back with a box. And the box is long enough. And it fits across the entire short side of the couch, where the armrests would be. So I start sweeping underneath the couch with my nightstick, trying to move the squirrel toward the box. Figuring we'll capture it and just get rid of it. And we'll be out of here. And there'll be no more mayhem.
我管她要个盒子。她说：“好的，我们有盒子。我们刚搬家。除了盒子什么也没有。”她跑去车库。她拿回一个盒子。盒子足够长。它正好跨过沙发短边，也就是扶手的位置。我开始用警棍在沙发底下扫荡，试图把松鼠赶向盒子。我想着我们要捉住它然后把它弄走。我们就能离开这了。就不会再有混乱了。
So it's actually working very well. And the squirrel's moving down along. You can hear it. It's chittering. And I'm trying not to hurt it. I'm nervous about the thing. It might bite me. I don't want to hurt it, really. It's just an animal.
所以其实进行得很好。松鼠正在顺着挪。你能听见它在叫。我尽量不去伤它。我对此很紧张。它可能会咬我。我真的不想伤它。它只是个动物。
So I'm moving it along. And everything's going very well. And then with about eight inches to go, I took one more swipe, and the thing just bolted out from underneath the couch. It was lined with tassels. I couldn't really see under the couch. It bolted out from underneath the couch and ran directly into the fireplace, which is about three feet away. The fireplace was directly head of it, and it ran into the fire, and caught on fire, and ran directly back out, and directly back under the couch.
所以我把它挪出来。一切进展顺利。然后当还剩八英寸时，我多扫了一下，那东西就直接从沙发底下冲了出来。沙发底边缝着流苏。我没法看清沙发下面。它冲了出来，直接跑向大约三英尺外的壁炉。壁炉就在它前方，它跑进了火里，身上着火了，又直接冲了出来，跑回沙发下面。
Is it on fire?
它着火了吗？
It was on fire. Yeah. The tail, the bushy fur, the whole bit. I mean, it wasn't, like, flaming or anything. But it was smoking. And there was a little bit of fire coming off the tail. So it runs back under the couch. And the couch catches on fire in seconds. I mean, in seconds. It must have had dust under there or something else. But it just caught on fire immediately.
它着火了。是的。尾巴、毛茸茸的毛皮，整个。我的意思是，并没有像喷火那样。但它冒烟了。尾巴上还带着点火光。所以它跑回沙发底下。几秒钟内沙发就烧着了。几秒钟。可能底下有灰尘或者别的什么东西。但它确实立刻就着火了。
And my partner and I just don't even talk. We just grab the couch, heave it upside down. And now there's plenty of oxygen for the fire to really get going. And it starts up. And we're patting it out. And it's sort of getting away from us. So we grab the only thing that's really available. And those are these really nice silk pillows. And we have one in each hand, the both of us. And we're just windmilling away at this fire on the couch. And we put it out.
我和我搭档连话都没说。我们直接抓住沙发，把它翻了个底朝天。现在火有了充足的氧气，真的烧起来了。火势开始蔓延。我们在拍打火苗。火有点不受控制了。所以我们抓起唯一能用的东西。那就是那些漂亮的丝绸枕头。我们每人一只手抓着一个。我们俩就挥着枕头拍打着沙发上的火。我们把它扑灭了。
But it's smoking terribly. And it was just a disaster. The couch is upside down. The bottom of it is burnt. The house is filling with smoke from the couch. The squirrel, when it went under the couch, in its death throes, just latched on  to the bottom of the couch. It's like this smoking piece of gristle underneath the couch, latched on there with its claws. And we're pounding, smearing it all over the place. And the smoke alarms are firing away. The guy is standing with handkerchiefs and paper towels up around his nose, which is still bleeding. His pajamas are a mess. They're covered with blood, the front of them.
但这烟熏得厉害，真是灾难。沙发是倒着的。底部烧毁了。屋子里充满了从沙发散发出的烟雾。松鼠跑到沙发底下时，在垂死挣扎中，死死抓住沙发底部。就像一块冒烟的烤肉黏在沙发底下，爪子死死扣在那里。我们在那猛拍，把残骸弄得到处都是。烟雾报警器响个不停。那男人用手帕和纸巾捂着鼻子站着，鼻子还在流血。他的睡衣一团糟。前襟全是血。
And we finally get the fire out. And we're both completely red. Sweating, because we're dressed for like zero degree weather, and it's hot there, by the fire. We're mortified. The house is full of smoke.
我们终于扑灭了火。我们俩脸全红了。满头大汗，因为我们穿着御寒装备，而火边很热。我们难堪极了。屋子里全是烟。
The wife just looks around and just starts to cry. She goes, what have you done? What have you done to my house? You can see her just clicking things off on the fingers. OK. The dead squirrel, ruined pillows, need a new couch, the walls are covered with soot, the fire alarms are going off, my husband's disfigured. And then she really kind of just lost it.
妻子只是环顾四周，开始哭起来。她说：“你们做了什么？你们对我的房子做了什么？”你能看见她用手指在数着损失：好吧。死松鼠，毁掉的枕头，需要新沙发，墙壁覆盖着煤烟，火灾报警器响个不停，我丈夫毁容了。然后她真的崩溃了。
And he was just looking at us and shaking his head, like he couldn't believe that these two idiots showed up and did this to his house over nothing, really. And he just goes, you know, you really haven't done anything wrong. I can't point to any one thing that you did that I have a reason to get angry about. You really haven't done anything wrong. I mean, we did call you. But I just, I can't thank you for this. They call for a squirrel. They end up with $3,000, $4,000 worth of damage and a broken nose. And this is all within about five minutes.
他看着我们，摇着头，好像不相信这两个白痴竟然为了这么点儿破事儿就闯进他家把房子毁了。他说：“你知道，你们确实没做错什么。我指不出你们做的哪一件事我有理由生气。你们真的没做错什么。我的意思是，确实是我们叫你们来的。但我只是，我没法为此感谢你们。”他们为了只松鼠报警。结果损失了三四千美元，鼻子还断了。这一切都发生在五分钟之内。
Could that have happened to you now, 13 years later?
13年后的今天，这事还能发生在你身上吗？
There's always a new mistake to be made. I don't think I would make that particular mistake. I mean, you make plenty of mistakes. That's just part of that job. You just try not to make the same one twice. But there's such variety that you're going to make hundreds, you're going to make thousands of mistakes, until you really get a handle on what you're doing.
总会有新的错误可以犯。我不认为我会犯那个特定的错误。我的意思是，你会犯很多错误。那只是那份工作的一部分。你只要尽量不要再犯同样的错误。但这类错误种类繁多，你会犯几百个、几千个错误，直到你真正掌握了你的工作。
That's interesting.  That is a very particular thing about a new job. Is that in order to learn the job, you literally have to make the mistakes. There's no way around it.
很有意思。这正是新工作的一个特殊之处。为了学习这份工作，你确实必须犯错。这是绕不开的。
Right. And with police work, they afford you plenty of space to make mistakes. But there are things that just aren't your responsibility-- if you get involved in things that aren't your responsibility, or that you're really not equipped to handle, or that you don't have a specific plan-- a plan that's thought through to a conclusion-- you probably should reevaluate what you're doing.
对。警察工作给了你足够的空间去犯错。但有些事情确实不是你的责任——如果你卷入了那些不属于你的责任，或者你根本没有能力处理，或者你没有一个具体的计划——一个深思熟虑的计划——你可能真的应该重新评估你在做什么。
Yeah, now that you mentioned that, that's right. You walked into the house, thinking, OK. We'll get this squirrel. Like, how were you going to get the squirrel? What was the best case scenario?
是的，你这么一说，没错。你走进那所房子时想的是：好吧，我们会抓住这只松鼠。就像，你打算怎么抓住那只松鼠？最好的结果是什么？
That's a great question. I guess I was thinking that I would go up there in the attic, and find this cowering squirrel, and somehow kind of lure it into some kind of trap, and then walk out with it and be like a hero. But as it turned out, it was a Pyrrhic victory for the squirrel, but the squirrel definitely won. The squirrel really kicked our ass.
这是个好问题。我想我当时觉得我会钻进阁楼，找到那只蜷缩的松鼠，用某种方法把它诱进陷阱，然后带着它走出来，像个英雄一样。但事实证明，这对松鼠来说是一次“皮洛士式胜利”（得不偿失的胜利），但那只松鼠无疑赢了。松鼠真的把我们打败了。
That is not what you want to be saying at the end of the day.
这不是你想要在一天结束时说的话。
No, no. It took me a long time to even tell people about it, you know? I was so new. I didn't want to know what a bonehead I was when I first came onto the job.
不，不。我甚至花了好久才敢告诉别人，你知道吗？我当时太菜了。我不想让他们知道我刚入职时有多么愚蠢。
Describe what you thought police work was going to be the day that you entered the academy.
描述一下你进入学院那天，你以为警察工作会是什么样子。
What I thought it would be was one adventure after another, kind of. And that sounds childish. But that's sort of what I did envision. And then one of the very first days I was on, I had the school crossing where I used to go to school. So at 23, I was crossing these kids where I had went to grammar school and I went to high school. Freezing cold. And I knew just about every third or fourth car that went by. And everyone's beeping and honking. And there was some slush on the ground.
我以为那会是一场接一场的冒险，大概吧。这听起来很幼稚。但那确实是我所设想的。然后我入职的第一天，我就负责那段我曾经上学时走过的学校路口。所以23岁的我，正护送着那些我曾经读过的语法学校和高中的孩子们过马路。天寒地冻。我认识每隔三四辆经过的车里的每一个人。每个人都在鸣笛打招呼。地上还有融化的雪水。
And my mother drove by. And she stopped in the middle of the intersection. And she goes, what are you doing out here without a hat on?
我母亲开车经过。她在路口中间停下了。她说：“你怎么没戴帽子就出来了？”
Loud enough for others to hear?
声音大到别人能听见吗？
Not at all. Not at all.
没，绝对没有。
Thank goodness for that.
谢天谢地。
You know, she just, what are you doing out here without a hat on? Mom, I have the hat I'm supposed to wear.  She's like, but it doesn't cover your ears. It's freezing out here.
你知道，她就是：“你怎么没戴帽子就出来？妈妈，我有按规定戴的帽子。”她说：“但那盖不住你的耳朵。外面冷死了。”
And that's when I started to realize, hey, this isn't all about car chases and everything else. It's just like living at home.
就在那时我开始意识到，嘿，这不是什么飞车追逐之类的。这就像住在家里一样。
Our interviewee has two years to retirement. He has been on the force for 18 years.
我们的受访者还有两年就退休了。他已经在警队服务了18年。
[MUSIC - "FOX SQUIRREL" BY MUDDY WATERS]
[音乐 - 穆迪·沃特斯 (Muddy Waters) 的《狐狸松鼠》]
Coming up, when friends try to act like more than just friends. When corporations try to act like high school freshmen. Bad sex, bad radio stations, and the power of a fuzzy navel. That's all in a minute, all of it, from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下里，当朋友试图不仅仅表现得像朋友时。当公司试图表现得像高中新生时。糟糕的性爱、糟糕的电台、还有模糊腹脐（Fuzzy Navel，一种鸡尾酒）的力量。这些都在一分钟后播出，这一切，都来自国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and performers and everyday people to come on and take a whack at that theme. Today's program, First Day. The story of outsiders arriving on the scene, trying to become insiders, and the peril inherent in that. We have arrived at Act Three of our show.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、表演者和普通人来尝试探讨这个主题。今天的节目是“第一天”。讲述局外人出现在现场，试图成为内部人，以及其中蕴含的危险。我们现在进入了节目的第三幕。
Act Three, Bad Sex with Bud Kemp.
第三幕，与巴德·肯普的糟糕性爱。
How can you do a program about first days without some story about the first day of a new relationship? We have this story from Sandra Tsing Loh in Los Angeles.
没有关于新恋情第一天的故事，怎么能做一个关于“第一天”的节目呢？我们有这样一个来自洛杉矶桑德拉·清·罗的故事。
Bud Kemp was a guy I'd known for eight years, first in college, then at the pharmaceutical corporation where I worked. I had always thought of Bud as a nice guy, and not unattractive. Not exactly attractive, either. I mean, he had good features-- tall, wavy brown hair, lanky build-- but there always seemed to be this kind of beaten quality to Bud-- in his sad smile, stooped shoulders, pear shape-- as though he were being flogged by life. Sexually, Bud Kemp was an inert object.
巴德·肯普是我认识八年的家伙，先是在大学，然后是在我工作的制药公司。我一直认为巴德是个好人，也不丑。但也称不上吸引人。我是说，他有很好的五官——个子高，波浪般的棕色头发，身材修长——但巴德身上总有一种受过打击的气质——他那忧伤的笑容、驼着的肩膀、梨形的身材——就好像他一直被生活鞭笞着。在性方面，巴德·肯普是个惰性物体。
That perception changed dramatically one night early in the summer of my 31st year. Although not really intimate, Bud and I were in the habit of going to the movies every Thursday night. This movie night tradition had been started by a little dorm group in college, although of course as members drifted towards 30, pairing up or marrying people from the outside, they'd left Bud, I, and movie night behind.
那种感觉在我31岁那年的夏天初发生了巨大的变化。虽然算不上亲密，但我有个习惯，每个周四晚上和巴德一起去看电影。这个电影之夜的传统是由大学里的一个小寝室团体发起的，虽然随着成员们临近30岁，开始配对或与外界的人结婚，他们留下了巴德和我，还有电影之夜。
No doubt, Bud had also tried to leave Bud, I, and movie night behind. I tried myself. But it was difficult. I mean, I've never been the sort of woman who walks into a room in a Lycra mini dress, hair moussed to staggering proportion, and the men just drop dead all around. No. My charms are more subtle. I'm the kind of girl guys fall back on. Tireless listener. Lender of money. Provider of Xanax. Ride to LAX. And so, as though held together by gravity, eight years later, Bud and I would still find ourselves sitting together in the darkened movie theater, clutching separate containers of popcorn, not saying a word. Hardly a date, I'd think.
毫无疑问，巴德也试图离开巴德、我和电影之夜。我自己也试过。但这很难。我的意思是，我从来不是那种穿着莱卡迷你裙、头发用摩丝打理到令人咋舌的程度，走入房间就能让男人们纷纷倒地的女人。不。我的魅力更微妙。我是那种男人们退而求其次选择的女孩。不知疲倦的倾听者。借钱的人。阿普唑仑（Xanax）的提供者。去机场的专车。所以，仿佛被引力维系着，八年后，巴德和我依然发现自己坐在黑暗的电影院里，紧紧抓着各自的爆米花盒，一言不发。我想，这算不上约会。
But one night during the opening credits, I looked over at Bud. And for the first time I realized what a sharp profile he had. What relatively clear skin. And his hands clasped together over one big knee. They were nice, too. Suddenly a phrase popped into my mind. "The strong, capable hands of Bud Kemp." Strong. Capable. Silent. Could this Bud Kemp be used for sex?
但有一个晚上在开场演职员表时，我看向巴德。我第一次意识到他的侧脸有多硬朗。皮肤相对有多干净。还有他紧扣在大腿上的一双手。也很好。突然一个短语出现在我脑海里。“巴德·肯普那双有力、能干的手。”有力。能干。沉默。这个巴德·肯普能用于性吗？
So things are getting hot, if in kind of a lukewarm way. The coming of our pharmaceutical corporation's summer softball league in Torrance makes them even hotter. Oh yeah. Once a year, summer softball provides we who labor in sector D7 with an excuse to just go wild. Wear funny raccoon hats with our team names on them, yell "whoo, whoo" for no reason at all.
事情变得火热起来，虽然是以一种不温不火的方式。我们制药公司的托兰斯夏季垒球联赛的到来让气氛更加热烈。噢，是的。一年一次，夏季垒球为我们这些在D7区工作的人提供了一个借口去疯狂一下。戴上带有我们球队名称的滑稽浣熊帽，无缘无故地大喊大叫。
My team, the Fly Balls, is composed mostly of  the four Fs of the softball universe. Skinny guys in Greenpeace teachers, reluctant wives and girlfriends, little [UNINTELLIGIBLE] from the mailroom. No wonder today we are being beaten, whipped dominated by Terminator 2000, the league leaders. Pitching for them today? Bud Kemp.
我的球队，“飞球队”（Fly Balls），主要由垒球界的“四眼族”组成。穿着绿色和平组织T恤的瘦弱男生，不情愿的妻子和女朋友，收发室来的小[不明]。难怪今天我们被联赛领头羊“终结者2000”打得落花流水、丢盔弃甲。今天为他们投球的人？巴德·肯普。
Oh, yeah. This is a little known fact about Bud Kemp. He did play a year of junior varsity basketball in college. So what if it was at a small science school with a 57-game losing streak? So what if Bud Kemp was thrown onto the court mainly for use as a human shield?
噢，是的。关于巴德·肯普有个鲜为人知的事实。他在大学时确实打过一年初级校队篮球。那又怎样？即使是在一所57场连败的小科学学校？即使巴德·肯普被派上场主要是为了当肉盾？
The point is, in sector D7, Bud Kemp is our sports stud. And a damned good-looking one, too. Hair faintly blonded under the sun, skin lightly tanned, and are those new glasses? God, yes. Instead of sad clown sideways teardrops, these are cool wire rims. Sting wears wire rims.
重点是，在D7区，巴德·肯普是我们的运动健将。而且还是个长相帅气的健将。阳光下淡淡发金的头发，稍微晒黑的皮肤，那是新眼镜吗？天哪，是的。不再是忧伤小丑般的侧垂泪滴造型，这些是酷酷的细铁框眼镜。斯汀（Sting）就戴这种细铁框。
Bud steps up to the mound, pulls off his t-shirt, and his naked torso is-- OK. 33 and holding, is the triumphal message here. Although he is so Schwarzenegger, there are definite suggestions of biceps and pecs. More than suggestions. Announcements, even. Not very loud announcements, but the point is, situps are being completed, racquetball played, body parts attended to, secretly anointed, perhaps. Is it just my third fuzzy navel talking, or is Bud Kemp ready for sex?
巴德走上投手丘，脱掉T恤，那裸露的躯干——好吧。33岁保持得还行，这是个胜利的信号。虽然他还没到施瓦辛格那种程度，但肱二头肌和胸肌的暗示还是很明显的。不止是暗示。甚至可以说是公告了。不是那种很大声的公告，但重点是，仰卧起坐完成了，壁球打了，身体部位得到了照顾，可能还秘密地涂抹了什么。是我的第三杯“模糊腹脐”在作祟，还是巴德·肯普确实准备好性爱了？
We're at Pizza Hut now, talking and laughing. Sex is definitely in the air tonight for everyone in sector D7. Beers slosh, music thumps, lamps sway. People in funny raccoon hats worm up against each other. Bud Kemp and I are no exception. Underneath the table, thigh to thigh, sweatpant to sweatpant, we're doing kind of a sensual leg thing. Laugh and kick out. Laugh and kick out.
我们现在在必胜客，边说边笑。今晚D7区的每个人空气中都弥漫着性气息。啤酒溅出，音乐轰鸣，灯光摇曳。戴着滑稽浣熊帽的人们互相磨蹭。巴德·肯普和我也不例外。桌子底下，大腿对大腿，运动裤对运动裤，我们正在进行某种感官接触。笑一笑，踢一下。笑一笑，踢一下。
Obviously, it's driving him wild. "So, you wanna go somewhere?" he says. "Like where, Bud?" I say. It is so loud and wild in here, no one would notice if you tore your own bra off and used it as a lasso. My case would be the sexy black bra I'd slipped on in the bathroom for a guy called Bud Kemp.
显然，这让他快疯了。“所以，你想去哪儿吗？”他说。“去哪儿，巴德？”我说。这里又吵又疯狂，就算你自己扯掉文胸把它当成套索挥舞，也没人会注意到。那种情况下，我会穿上那天我在洗手间专门为巴德·肯普这种家伙穿上的那件性感黑色文胸。
"Away from here." "How about your place?" "Sounds great." "All righty, then." "All righty."
“离开这儿。”“去你家怎么样？”“听起来棒极了。”“好极了。”“好极了。”
We are using secret code now. Bud Kemp and I are talking, moving as one. I sense almost by telepathy he wants to swing by the Lucky for a six pack. We skate effortlessly through the gleaming, luminescent supermarket aisles like Torvilll and Dean. We pause calmly, almost worshipfully, before the glass refrigerator cases, which present their dramatic panoramas. Endless vistas of possibility. Heineken, Dos Equis, Tsingtao, Kirin, Moosehead, Foster's. The whole world is ours, literally, through beer.
我们现在在用暗号交流。巴德·肯普和我正在交谈，像一个人一样行动。我几乎通过心灵感应感觉到他想顺便去超市买六罐装啤酒。我们毫不费力地在灯光通明的超市通道中滑行，就像花样滑冰组合托维尔和迪恩一样。我们在冷藏柜前平静地停下，几乎是怀着崇敬的心情，那里展示着戏剧性的全景。无尽的可能性的前景。喜力、多斯奎斯、青岛、麒麟、慕斯海德、福斯特。整个世界确实通过啤酒呈现在我们面前。
He chooses Coors. I say, "I like it too." "I guess we both like it," he says. We both like it.
他选了酷尔斯（Coors）。我说：“我也喜欢。”“我想我们俩都喜欢，”他说。我们俩都喜欢。
And suddenly I have a vision of Bud Kemp and I together on a Sunday morning, reading the newspaper, drinking our favorite General Foods International Coffee, Amaretto Hazelnut, the one we both like. And instead of my weekends yawning empty, I will be spending them with someone, together, liking things. First it was movies. Now it is beer. Soon it will be cars, vacations, houses, children.
突然，我产生了一个愿景：巴德·肯普和我在一起的某个周日早上，读着报纸，喝着我们最喜欢的通用食品公司国际咖啡，杏仁榛子口味的，我们俩都喜欢的那个。而我的周末不再是无聊的空虚，我会和某个人一起度过，在一起，喜欢着同样的东西。起初是电影。现在是啤酒。很快就会是汽车、假期、房子、孩子。
This is the vision I cling onto as we returned to his condo in Long Beach, drained the beer, moved to leftover Gallo, as I sit in the living room and rub and rub and rub Bud Kemp's shoulders, and Bud Kemp talks and talks and talks about-- what else?-- Bud Kemp. "So sometimes I wonder if I'm really, really suited for a career in pharmaceuticals marketing management. I mean, what if my calling is something a bit more in the applied plastics field?" "What kind of plastics did you have in mind, Bud?" "Oh, I don't know. Single cell liposome polymer blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, me, me, me, blah, blah, blah, me, me, me, blah, blah, blah, me, me."
这就是我回到他位于长滩的公寓时紧紧抓住的愿景，喝干了啤酒，改喝剩下的盖洛（Gallo）红酒，当我坐在客厅里不断按摩巴德·肯普的肩膀时，巴德·肯普喋喋不休地谈论着——还能是什么呢？——巴德·肯普。“所以我有时会想，我是否真的、真的适合从事医药营销管理。我的意思是，如果我的天职是在应用塑料领域呢？”“巴德，你指的是哪种塑料？”“哦，我不知道。单细胞脂质体聚合物，巴拉巴拉巴拉，我我我，巴拉巴拉巴拉，我我我。”
He is making me lose hold of my vision. We need to escalate things to the next level. "Bud," I say, "let's go to bed."
他让我失去了愿景的掌控。我们需要把事情升级到下一个层次。“巴德，”我说，“我们上床吧。”
The moon slants in through the shade, transforming everything into misshapen lumps. It is uncomfortably warm and stuffy. Bud is lying on his bed, fully clothed, frozen. "This is so weird," he says, "after all this time."
月光斜斜地透过窗帘，把一切都变成了形状扭曲的块状物。这里闷热得让人不舒服。巴德躺在床上，衣冠整齐，僵住了。“这太奇怪了，”他说，“这么多年之后。”
"I know," I say. "But I think you'll like it."
“我知道，”我说。“但我认为你会喜欢的。”
I sit on the edge of the bed, remove one shoe, then the other. Bud Kemp does not move, make any invitation. I shove in next to him. Suddenly horny, in a kind of confused, primeval way, we grapple each other like circus bears. Bud Kemp's head is buried in my shoulder. He is stroking my hair with these odd petting motions, making this kind of humming sound. [HUMMING]
我坐在床边，脱掉一只鞋，又脱掉另一只。巴德·肯普没动，也没发出任何邀请。我挤到他旁边。突然感到一种困惑、原始的欲望，我们像马戏团的熊一样纠缠在一起。巴德·肯普的头埋在我的肩膀里。他用那种古怪的爱抚动作抚摸我的头发，发出那种嗡嗡的声音。[嗡嗡声]
I find myself energetically massaging his shoulders. I don't know why. Move down. Lower back. Move down. Buttocks. But it seems invasive to be massaging the buttocks of such an old friend, so I find myself merely patting them as though in congratulation.
我发现自己充满活力地按摩着他的肩膀。我不知道为什么。往下移。下背部。往下移。臀部。但按摩一个老朋友的臀部似乎太冒犯了，所以我发现自己只是拍了拍它们，好像在表示祝贺。
Oh, if only we could get that sensual leg thing going again. Laugh and kick out. Laugh and kick out. But there is no laughter here. Only worry and sweat. How I long for Pizza Hut with its pepperoni-laced orgy-like ambiance. Sex between two people can be such a lonely thing.
噢，如果能再重现那种感官接触就好了。笑一笑，踢一下。笑一笑，踢一下。但这里没有笑声。只有忧虑和汗水。我是多么渴望必胜客那种弥漫着意大利辣香肠的纵欲氛围啊。两人之间的性爱竟能是如此孤独的一件事。
Grimly pushing on, I tear my t-shirt off, revealing my sexy black bra, his cue to just go wild. But Bud Kemp is rubbing his eyes with both hands. Still I wait, with accusing breasts. Still Bud rubs, making that kind of faint humming sound. [HUMMING]
痛苦地继续着，我扯掉T恤，露出我那性感的黑色文胸，这是他疯狂起来的信号。但巴德·肯普用双手揉着眼睛。我依然在那等着，挺着那双充满控诉感的乳房。巴德依然在揉着，发出那种微弱的嗡嗡声。[嗡嗡声]
And I realize that Bud Kemp can not bring himself to face my breasts in all their terrible candor. They blaze in the darkness like headlights, illuminating the falseness of all of those movie nights. Eventually, Bud stops running and just lies there with both hands cupped over his eyes, as though expecting to be flogged. His nostrils quiver. Is that a snore?
我意识到，巴德·肯普无法面对我乳房那种可怕的坦诚。它们在黑暗中像大灯一样闪耀，照亮了那些电影之夜所有的虚假。最终，巴德停止了揉眼睛，双手捧着脸躺在那里，仿佛等待着被鞭笞。他的鼻孔翕动。那是呼噜声吗？
My idea is that we will never speak of the incident again, see each other, or even continue to live in the same state. But no. The bouquet that arrived the next morning is the ugliest I have ever seen. It is a chaos of white baby's breath, purple lupin, pink carnations, yellow daisies, all stabbing against each other in frantic counterpoint. Even worse is the card, which reads, "I saw these flowers and thought of you. Love, Bud."
我的想法是我们以后再也不要提起这件事，不见面，甚至不要住在同一个州。但并没有。第二天早上送来的花束是我见过最丑的。那是白色的满天星、紫色的羽扇豆、粉红色的康乃馨、黄色的雏菊在疯狂地互相交织，打着架。更糟的是那张卡片，上面写着：“看到这些花就想到了你。爱你的，巴德。”
Love, Bud. One thing is for sure. He is not my lovebud, and this is not me at age 31, a frantic bouquet slowly wilting.
爱你的，巴德。有一件事是肯定的。他不是我的爱人，我也不是31岁，那是一个正在慢慢枯萎的狂乱花束。
Sandra Tsing Loh's story "Bad Sex with Bud Kemp" is not collected in her books Aliens in America, A Year in Van Nuys, or any of her fine books. She has been happily married for years to a man who is not in any way, any way, Bud Kemp. They live in Los Angeles.
桑德拉·清·罗的故事《与巴德·肯普的糟糕性爱》并未收录在她的书籍《美国的异乡人》、《范奈斯的一年》或任何她的优秀作品中。她多年来一直与一位绝非巴德·肯普的男人幸福地生活在一起。他们住在洛杉矶。
[MUSIC - "THE FIRST TIME" BY EYDIE GORME]
[音乐 - 伊迪·戈梅 (Eydie Gorme) 的《第一次》]
Act Four, When Businesses Act Like People.
第四幕，当企业像人类一样行事。
We have this case study from Alex Blumberg, a radio listener-- a radio listener like you, a radio listener like me-- here in Chicago.
我们有这样一个来自广播听众亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）的案例研究——一位像你一样的听众，一位像我一样的听众——这里在芝加哥。
This is a story about a first day that's in denial that it's a first day. The story starts when I was in my car. And I just realized that I have my preset station buttons arranged in order of preference. One, two, three, four, five, six. And so I sort of go down. And this station number six was the classic rock station, Rock 103. And number six is often just awful. Every once in a while, they'll have a good Led Zeppelin song on, and that's why I have it set.
这是一个关于拒绝承认自己是“第一天”的第一天的故事。故事开始时我正开车。我意识到我把收音机预设频道按偏好顺序排列好了。一、二、三、四、五、六。所以我按顺序按。第六个频道是经典摇滚台，Rock 103。六号位通常烂透了。偶尔他们会放一首好的齐柏林飞艇（Led Zeppelin）的歌，所以我才设了它。
So I hit it, and there's that song, which I don't know the name of, but it's that one that goes, "ooh, child, things are going to get easier." And I think to myself, that's certainly an expansive definition of classic rock. So then I think, wow, this is great. And then another song comes on. And it's "Disco Inferno," or something like that.
所以我按了它，传出了那首歌，我不知道名字，但就是那首唱着“噢，孩子，事情会变得更容易”的歌。我想，那对经典摇滚的定义可真是够宽泛的。然后我想，哇，这太棒了。然后又出来一首歌。是“迪斯科地狱”（Disco Inferno），或者诸如此类的。
And I think now, something must be wrong. So I look and I think, the first thing is that somebody's been messing with my dials. Like somebody got into my car and rearranged my radio stations. But then I look at the numbers. The numbers are the same.
我心想，一定是哪里出错了。所以我看看，心想，第一件事就是有人动了我的旋钮。就像有人钻进我的车里重排了我的广播频道。但接着我看了看数字。数字是一样的。
And then I hear this announcement that comes on. And it's like, "You've found the new 1035, Jammin' Oldies." And I think to myself, what the hell is a jammin' oldie? And you have to keep in mind that the day before, this station had been playing Anthrax and Slayer, and every once in a while, like I said, a Led Zeppelin song, but basically heavy metal gearhead music. And now all of a sudden, there's just no mention being made of it. And it's just like the old station was disappeared.
然后我听到了这样的广播通告。就像，“你找到了全新的103.5，Jammin' Oldies（劲爆老歌）。”我心想，这玩意儿到底什么是“劲爆老歌”？你必须记住，前一天，这个电台还在放Anthrax和Slayer（金属乐队），就像我说的，偶尔放一首齐柏林飞艇的歌，但基本上是重金属齿轮发烧友的音乐。而现在突然之间，完全没有提及那件事。就像旧电台被抹掉了一样。
You've found the new 1035. Chicago's new station for jammin' oldies. We don't play moldy oldies, and we don't play doo-wop--
你找到了全新的103.5。芝加哥播放劲爆老歌的全新电台。我们不播霉变的老歌，也不播杜沃普（doo-wop）——
Now what has happened is that this station had a format change over the weekend, basically. And they didn't mention it on the weekend, when I had been listening before. There was no mention of it. They were doing their concert promotions and having people call up to get Anthrax tickets or whatever. Nothing had been said.
现在发生的情况是，这个电台基本上在周末改了台风。他们周末的时候提都没提，那时我还听着呢。完全没有提及。他们当时还在做演唱会推广，让人们打电话赢取Anthrax的票什么的。什么都没说。
And so obviously, everybody who has been tuning in before is expecting the classic rock. But they don't want to seem like they're a new station. They don't want to seem like the new kid on the block.
所以显然，所有之前一直在收听的人都期待着经典摇滚。但他们不想表现得像个新电台。他们不想看起来像个新来乍到的家伙。
So what they do, is they do what everybody does on the first day. They pretend like it's not the first day. They want to establish this illusion that they've been around forever, so they have these little promo spots that come on, these little [UNINTELLIGIBLE] where they have people they've interviewed-- like, man on the street interviews-- where people are talking about how great jammin' oldies are, and how wonderful it is to have this station that plays jammin' oldies which has been on the radio for three hours.
所以他们怎么做呢？他们像任何人在第一天做的那样。他们假装这不是第一天。他们想要建立一种仿佛已经存在了很久的错觉，所以他们做了这些小广告，这些[不明]，采访了一些人——就像街头采访——人们谈论着劲爆老歌有多棒，拥有这个已经开播了三小时的劲爆老歌电台有多美妙。
Everybody's talking about the new station that plays Chicago's jammin' oldies.
每个人都在谈论这个播放芝加哥劲爆老歌的新电台。
You know, when you hear those songs, it brings you back, like you're right there.
你知道，当你听到那些歌时，它带你回到了过去，就像你就身临其境一样。
You know? Like, what did they do? They just start broadcasting, and immediately send a squad of people out to find people who are accidentally tuned in? No.
你知道吗？他们做了什么？他们就直接开始广播，然后立刻派出一队人去寻找偶然调频到这的人吗？没有。
And that also comes through. I mean, if you hear the spots, it's like this sort of desperately-- It's like they're trying too hard. And it's just exactly what happens when you're trying to fit in too hard, and you're pretending like you've around forever, and you know the ropes, and it just falls flat. And these spots just fall flat.
这也能听得出来。我的意思是，如果你听那些广告，就像是一种绝望的……就像他们太努力了。这完全就是当你拼命想要融入、假装自己在这儿待很久了、知道门道时发生的事，结果却适得其反。这些广告听起来就很生硬。
The one that I love is where they have, like, "This is the station that plays jammin' oldies." And then they cut to this voice of somebody going, "jammin' oldies!"
我最喜欢的一段是他们说：“这是播放劲爆老歌的电台。”然后切到一个人的声音喊道：“劲爆老歌！”
Now here comes more of Chicago's jammin' oldies.
现在带来更多芝加哥的劲爆老歌。
Jammin' oldies!
劲爆老歌！
On the new 103--
在全新的103——
I don't quite understand what it is that is just so ridiculous about that particular "jammin' oldies." But it's just like it's so earnest and so wrong. It's just not right. It's just not what somebody would say if they were actually excited about jammin' oldies. They would never-- I can't imagine a situation in which somebody would authentically be shouting "jammin' oldies! Jammin' oldies!" A jammin' oldies pep rally? I can't imagine where it would be happening.
我不太理解那种特定的“劲爆老歌”到底哪里那么荒谬。但听起来就是那么诚恳又那么不对劲。简直太不对了。如果有人真的对劲爆老歌感到兴奋，他们绝对不会那样说。我无法想象有什么情况下会有人真正发自内心地大喊“劲爆老歌！劲爆老歌！”劲爆老歌动员大会吗？我无法想象那会在哪儿发生。
I mean, I have nothing in common with the station formerly known as Rock 103. And yet, all the behaviors that they are exhibiting on their first day are behaviors that I would exhibit on my first day anywhere. Like they are trying to fit in, they're expressing sort of this anxious enthusiasm, the false bravado. They're pretending to have experienced things that they have, in fact, not experienced. And they're failing miserably, just as I would fail miserably, and have, on many occasions, on my first day.
我是说，我和那个前身为Rock 103的电台没有任何共同点。然而，他们在第一天表现出的所有行为，都是我会在任何地方的第一天表现出的行为。比如他们试图融入，他们表现出一种焦虑的热情、虚假的虚张声势。他们假装经历了他们实际上从未经历过的事情。而且他们惨败了，就像我在很多场合的第一天也会惨败一样。
Alex Blumberg.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格。
Well, it's This American Life , the radio program that can not resist a dare. Our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself with Alix Spiegel, Julie Snyder, and Emi Takahara. Our staff for this show includes Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton, Blue Chevigny, Todd Bachmann, and Starlee Kine. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, Alix Spiegel, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Marketing help from [? Marge Estrusco ?] and the friendly folks at PRI. Elizabeth Meister runs our website.
好了，这里是《美国生活》，那个无法抗拒挑战的广播节目。我们今天的节目由南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和我本人制作，联合制作人还有阿里克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）、朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）和艾米·高原（Emi Takahara）。节目组还包括亚历克斯·布隆伯格、苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、蓝色·切维尼（Blue Chevigny）、托德·巴赫曼（Todd Bachmann）和斯塔莉·凯恩（Starlee Kine）。特约编辑保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）、杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）、玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）、阿里克斯·斯皮格尔和顾问莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）。市场营销帮助来自[？玛吉·埃斯特鲁斯科]和国际公共广播电台（PRI）的朋友们。伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）负责我们的网站。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[鸣谢]
We've been meaning to thank Jorge Just for a few weeks now, so let's do it now. Thanks, J.
我们一直想感谢豪尔赫·贾斯特（Jorge Just），几周了，现在就感谢一下。谢谢你，J。
To buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago. 312-948-4712. Or visit our website where you can order tapes. Or you can listen to our programs for absolutely free online at www.thisamericanlife.org.
如需购买本节目或任何节目的录音带，请拨打我们芝加哥WBEZ的电话。312-948-4712。或者访问我们的网站，你可以订购磁带。或者你也可以在www.thisamericanlife.org免费在线收听我们的节目。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Funding for our show comes from the listeners of WBEZ Chicago. WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who walks into our studio at the end of every single show to grimly assess the damage.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。节目的资金来源是芝加哥WBEZ的听众。WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责，他每期节目结束时都会走进我们的工作室，冷酷地评估损失。
Dead squirrel. Ruined pillows. Need a new couch. The walls are covered with soot. The fire alarms are going off.
死松鼠。毁掉的枕头。需要新沙发。墙壁覆盖着煤烟。火灾报警器响个不停。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
You really haven't done anything wrong. I mean, we did call you. But I just-- I can't thank you for this.
你真的没做错什么。我的意思是，确实是我们叫你们来的。但我只是，我没法为此感谢你们。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。